[Música]
i
yo soy originario de una ciudad se llama
tecamachalco una ciudad pequeña
provinciana de pueblo y estaba en una
tarde de verano
dando un paseo con mi pareja y
6 un silencio extendido
ella me volteó a ver con sus ojos ser
óleos cálidos y me dijo de una manera
determinada
necesito que nos vayamos de tecamachalco
yo la vi sorprendido sabiendo que no
estaba admitiendo ninguna negativa y le
dije tú me conoces por miedoso y ella me
dijo no
en ese momento sabía que estábamos de
frente a un cambio sustantivo que íbamos
a tener en los siguientes días y que
estábamos buscando algo diferente
tenemos que cambiar algo y en este caso
ella quería un camino diferente para
nuestros hijos y obviamente esa era mi
prioridad también en esos días de cara a
una situación que era algo compleja
iñigo y emilio están diagnosticados con
autismo y las posibilidades que teníamos
en nuestra pequeña ciudad habían sido
agotadas en las escuelas no los
comprendían
en los juegos de los parques los niños
los señalaban y nosotros sentíamos
frustración porque no encontrábamos una
manera consistente de ayudarlos no tenía
alternativa
teníamos que crecer juntos porque era la
única manera
lo que una tribu tiene en común parece
tener más jerarquía que lo que hay en
cualquiera de nuestros planes personales
vivimos en comunidad y en equipo
encontramos los estados de mayor
trascendencia en nuestras vidas quiero
que pensemos en esto el momento antes de
que les diga 43 casos que yo aprendí de
los conflictos que tenemos que tuvimos
perdón que pasar en pareja
la perspectiva de vida cambia cuando
tienes un tercer ojo la innovación se
detona cuando un nuevo punto de vista
entra en tu mente
el primer truco es esto una pareja te da
una perspectiva nutritiva y les quiero
contar una historia hace un año mi
abuelo tomás murió
los gemelos eran los consentidos del
abuelo tomás y el cuidaba a sus pascuas
para que en diciembre florecieran y un
día me dijo poncho yo veo que tienes una
cámara me puedes tomar una foto con mis
nietos y yo le dije claro que si tu y
nos sentamos y me platicó algunas cosas
de su vida pasada y yo le dije a modo de
promesa toma yo te voy a llevar otra vez
a recorrer todos esos lugares que me
pláticas para que los vuelvas a
disfrutar y porque tú eres mi abuelo y
creo que vale la pena porque somos una
tribu lo platicamos
pasaron meses creo que un poco más de un
año y yo estaba haciendo agenda con
algunos clientes y algunos socios para
el fin de semana y llegó la misma
muchacha que en la tarde de verano me
dijo que nos fuéramos y me dijo
sin decirme más tú le prometiste atom un
viaje y ya pasaron muchos meses y no has
hecho nada
y yo le dije
no me gusta decírtelo pero tiene razón
cancele todo le hablé por teléfono y le
dije ton
ya sé que no estás haciendo nada prepara
tu bikini no vamos a ir de viaje vamos a
salir este fin de semana fuimos a todos
los lugares que quiso hicimos todas las
paradas que hicieron falta le compré
todo lo que quiso y al final tuvimos una
comida en familia
con el mejor ron que he probado en una
pequeña comunidad hay en veracruz
yo creo que no lo hubiera hecho si no
hubiera tenido a alguien que me aportará
una perspectiva nutritiva diferente en
el momento adecuado y probablemente es
el mejor recuerdo de vida que tengo de
mi abuelo que ahora está en el cielo
viendo qué bien me porto
la segunda cosa es el buen humor
yo sé que la cara no me ayuda de por si
soy un poco chistoso
y el buen humor me ayuda a despresurizar
los problemas y los conflictos que
tenemos en la vida diaria quién es mi
pareja mi compañera y yo y no tengo
alternativa quiero hacer énfasis en eso
no tengo alternativa porque la vida de
por si se nos puso un poquito complicada
de arranque no
el cínico uno de los gemelos
tuvimos la necesidad de internarlo un
día había mucho estrés
y cada vez que hemos enfrentado una
situación como esta que son muy
constantes alguien se echa un chiste y
no es como que mejore la situación pero
mejora nuestra actitud cuando ella y yo
nos hicimos novios a los pocos días yo
le dije oye sabes que tengo un problema
con esta situación y me siento
angustiado y ya me dijo eres un tonto
me puedes tomar fotos
y las vendes y vas a tener mucho dinero
en pocos días y obviamente memoria de
las risas así se las tome de no vendí
nada
pero ustedes siempre pueden contarle
algo que le dé risa el que está junto y
le van a mejorar su día siempre y tal
vez no lo están aprovechando el buen
humor mantenerme optimista fue algo que
aprendí de tener una pareja
y también nos ayudó a que íñigo salir
adelante sin que nos angustiamos mucho
como ustedes saben las personas que
están diagnosticadas con autismo
necesitan mucho apoyo entonces un día no
es una gran conclusión es la gran
ciencia pero le dije look tú y yo no nos
podemos morir muy pronto porque estos
chamacos necesitan que los ayudemos
mucho tiempo que los apoyemos y que
logremos que sean independientes y
autosuficientes de la mejor manera que
el entendimiento nos genere el estrés
como lo dicen los estudios de la cloud
tienen una alta correlación con la
muerte y con la enfermedad
además de mejorar tus relaciones de
pareja el hecho de que tengas buen humor
los va a estar alejando siempre de la
muerte y va a hacer que tengan más poder
para lograr algunas cosas así que rían
se mucho
i
cuando yo era chiquito tenía una tía que
era muy chistosa y me decía cuando algo
grave pasaba o alguien te hacía una
grosería mandan los archivos a un baile
con los años y con la maldad de entendí
que era una picardía pero
nosotros mi pareja y yo vivimos
situaciones muy complicadas y
estresantes a lo largo de la vida con
los niños porque de repente podía
tirarse y hacer rabietas infinitas
porque no tenía resistencia a ciertos
ruidos oa ciertas situaciones y la gente
pasaba y te señalaba o te hacía gestos
de desaprobación y a veces en la escuela
teníamos situaciones duras y no teníamos
alternativa más que que nos valiera no
tenía porque no tenemos oportunidad no
podía darle cabida que me importará qué
piensa qué opina
si yo lo tenía que tenía que atender era
a mi chiquito no tenía que sacarlo
adelante ese es la tercera cosa que
aprendimos no te tiene que importar
demasiado el mundo que está allá afuera
porque tienes que estar enfocado en tu
propósito en lo que tú quieres lograr
me encanta esta onda de la psicología
positiva
seligman afirma y yo estoy totalmente de
acuerdo con él que desarrollar niños
optimistas y resilientes les va a dar
muchas fortalezas para sobreponerse a
momentos de tristeza y que además van a
impulsar siempre su desarrollo escolar y
su salud física y se imaginan ustedes
creen que haya alguna otra cosa que yo
desee más que esto pues naturalmente no
aquí quise hacer una pequeña pausa
porque cuando iba construyendo esta
charla yo me di cuenta de que esto tenía
una enorme correlación con otro pequeño
aspecto de la vida desde hace un tiempo
yo me dedicado a aspectos de
emprendimiento e innovación y yo pensé
que me salían porque yo era pues como
bueno no en algunas cosas y caí en
cuenta de que nada de lo que aprendí o
de lo que sé hacer habría sido posible
sin estos tres previos aprendizajes que
logré únicamente por tener a una mujer
junto a mí
lo primero que aprendí que tiene que ver
con la innovación dice
una definición que a mí me agrada que la
innovación es ver lo que todos ven pero
pensar lo que nadie ha pensado y cómo
crees que construyes una visión más
integral de las cosas y de la vida
es teniendo un punto de vista diferente
y permanente en tu vida y eso es lo que
una pareja les puede otorgar cuando la
tienen a un lado y su pareja es
apreciada y ustedes la aprecian van a
tener un punto de vista distinto que les
va a dar poder para comprender el mundo
de una manera en la que no la
comprendían
la segunda cosa que yo me caí en cuenta
que es como una sospecha mía es que
cuando alguien es mejor en una cosa
normalmente el otro es mejor en otra
cosa yo podría pensar que tal vez yo
tengo un mejor control de la ira pero
que tal vez ella es mejor tomando
decisiones financieras
eso significa que yo puedo ser su master
controlando los enojos y ella puede ser
la master comprando el súper
y al revés ella puede ser muy ordenada y
yo puedo ser muy metódico necesitamos
reconocer que vamos a hacer en una
relación de pareja siempre maestro y
aprendiz y cuando yo pienso esto me
pongo a pensar porque hay parejas que
tienen 20 o 30 años con los mismos
problemas de hace mucho tiempo y lo que
yo creo es que esas parejas que no han
resuelto problemas viejitos es porque
nunca han aceptado que en unas partes
son bien buenos y en otras partes son
bien tontos y que la humildad para
entender que eres maestro y aprendiz te
va a permitir a lo largo del tiempo
generar la mayor cantidad de valor y ser
la mejor versión de ti mismo es lo que
yo creo desde lo que estoy convencido
voy a decirles el último truco que yo
aprendí de las relaciones de pareja le
llamo yo la gesta heróica
el mar que no está en calma nosotros
hemos tenido una vida de muchos
problemas una vida de altibajos en el
aspecto sentimental en el aspecto
financiero en el aspecto personal como
la mayoría de me imagino de todos
ustedes pero entendimos que así estaba
bien y que es un poco la vida un mar que
no está en calma no te enseña gran cosa
la imperfección como constante tener
unos hijos que la gente mira diferente
nos enseñaron a ver la imperfección
entrecomillada como uno de los atributos
que nos daba más valor en la vida ser
imperfectos es ser fantástico y la
última la dificultad como el método
esto me recuerda yo jugué videojuegos
desde chiquito que cuando tú lo tu te
metés al nivel 1 las dificultades son
pequeñas lo bonito de llegar al nivel 8
es que eres capaz de resolver problemas
más grandes mientras más tiempo y más
logres en pareja lo que vas a poder
resolver va a tener más importancia más
valor y más dificultad
me encanta que el día de hoy pueda ser
pueda dar una visión de un hombre
respecto a los problemas que las mujeres
se enfrentan y yo creo que los problemas
de inequidad de injusticia de
desigualdad en las mujeres y en los
hombres deben de ser resueltos y creo
que todos debemos de poner de nuestra
parte para que así sea sin embargo
cuando yo escucho a las mujeres tratando
de abolir la brecha salarial o los
espacios para ocupar algunos puestos me
parece que es su búsqueda es la mejor y
creo que así debe de ser pero a veces me
pregunto si no valdría la pena ir a
algunos pasos atrás y darnos cuenta de
que en algún momento y quizá es culpa o
fue culpa de los hombres miramos a la
mujer diferente y le otorgamos un valor
distinto pero eso no es determinante
nosotros podemos volver a mirarnos con
ojos nuevos con ojos amorosos y con toda
la serenidad del universo reconocer
que si somos iguales y nuestro mayor
valor está cuando estamos juntos y nos
construimos todas las desigualdades nos
van a parecer absurdas y esa lucha por
obtener estas cosas desaparecería porque
no existiría muchas gracias
[Aplausos]